it's time to step into the animus once
again
and head to england as viking raiders in
assassin's creed valhalla
it's a sprawling game with many things
to do so here are 10 beginners tips
to help you get the most out of it
unlike assassin's creed odyssey valhalla
isn't as loot based meaning that new
weapons and armor that are worth
swapping your faves for
won't come around as often that means
you should constantly be on the lookout
for resources to upgrade your stuff with
hold the right thumbstick to activate
odinsight to highlight resources in your
surroundings
keep a close eye out for leather whether
that's while loosing or by hunting
animals
and head to the mountains to break rocks
to grab those all-important ores
i don't think any of us expected viking
rap battles to play a part in valhalla
but here we are
your tongue is fat you're a sprat you
whine like a little brat
and we are in a spot says the flighter
who hides in a hole like a rat
you'll find various people around the
world who want to sling rhythmic
insults with you complete these and
you'll up your charisma level which will
unlock more conversation topics for you
there are different kinds of side
activities in valhalla
on top of traditional side quests there
are world events and mysteries too
these aren't tracked in your quest log
are typically much shorter than
traditional quests
and usually don't require that much
travel
completing them can get you all sorts of
worthwhile rewards and some
are pretty funny now i leave this world
enjoy your life too as asgards
wait thank you
but beware most of valhalla's coolest
secrets and best side missions
aren't even marked on your map even
after you've synchronized a waypoint
think like link in breath of the wild if
something on your map
or in the distance looks cool chances
are you'll find a hidden tomb
side quest or even hidden boss there
let's play boy
[Music]
skills and abilities work a little
differently in valhalla
leveling up grants you two skill points
which you can invest into
a pretty huge skill tree that lets you
develop your melee
ranged or stealth capabilities it seems
daunting but you can
respect your points at any point for
free so
experiment skills are mostly passive
buffs
so if you're looking for special moves
like chucking axes at dudes
head to the abilities menu abilities
aren't unlockable skills you earn by
leveling up you need to find
golden books of knowledge dotted around
the world to get them
they're usually hidden or require you to
complete some kind of puzzle to nab them
but trust me they're very worth it this
is pretty much a given
in an rpg but talk to everyone in your
settlement
especially newcomers this is how you
find new allies
spark romances and gain secret abilities
like a wolf that joins you in
battle you heard me right also fyi
people in your settlement can die so
make sure to spend time with your faves
while you can
because you never know what tragedy
might befall them
heiser
make sure to fix the barracks in your
settlement and create your own unique
yom's viking this lieutenant is sent out
to other valhalla games online and if
hired by other players
will earn you some easy money
[Music]
there are a bunch of godlike animals
scattered throughout
england i must have missed them if you
find and kill them you can have them
stuffed and put on display in your long
house
you'll need to make sure you invest in
the hunter shop back at your settlement
before you can do this
make sure to turn in your order of the
ancients medallions to the hidden one's
bureau to unlock powerful new abilities
turning in four will let you coat your
weapons and arrows in poison
which is super useful for boss fights
[Music]
there's a cute cat that hates most
people but loves sailors
if you want to find it follow oswald's
quest line and it's a random world side
event activity
that occurs towards the end of it once
you've found it the cat will join your
longboat crew when you go raiding
meow this may seem oddly specific but in
one of the early quests you'll be tasked
with finding a yellow longboat
using a cool and totally not overused
detective-like vision
you'll track the boat via some yellow
paint drops
to a river but the boat won't be there
from there you will be asked to find the
boat in
the swamps the game gives you little
direction from this point forward so
pinpointing this boat proved to be
a pain in the ass assassin
for us so here's a tip if you want to
try and find it on your own
stop listening right now but if you're
tired of looking you can find the yellow
boat
right here north of middleton and
between these two islands
so there you are 10 beginners tips for
your time in assassin's creed valhalla
if you've got more drop them in the
comments below and we may make a
follow-up video
for more on valhalla including graphics
comparisons between the xbox one x
and xbox series x keep it gamespot
[Music]
you